hello everyone and welcome to the final
game will be showing from the London
chest classic Grantchester finals it's
Magnus Carlsen vs. Levin Aragon we
already seen a game from the classical
portion where Coulson won and he was
awarded six points since the class a win
in the classical is awarded six points
and we saw a game where Magnus blundered
that game the first game of the rapids
where 11 got 4 points a rapid game is
worth 4 points and now this is the
second game of the rapid rapid section a
really enjoyable game where they repeat
the line they played in the classic also
Magnus again goes for the London system
but it's Levin who chooses a different
path sort of an improved line but the
game is overall is very interesting and
I would just like to thank everyone for
help
helping me with my special request
yesterday yeah you guys are the best
that being said let's check out the game
Magnus opens with d4 and like I said we
will be following the line from the
classical game from being one night of
3d 5 and the bishop to f4 we go for the
Magnus goes for the London system we
have c5 same as in Game one
III Knights the c6 and now Knight B to
d2 sorry about that
so C captures on d4 11 trades once on d4
captures captures in the Queen to b6 now
again putting pressure on d4 and also on
the b2 pawn so nice to be three taking
care of both threats and now a six we
already mentioned that Bishop f5 and g4
are known moves in the position but 11
goes for a 6 and it was a new move in
the game one of the classical time
section but it's not anymore since they
the two of them already played it so
Bishop e2 we have - up the g4 now
putting pressure on the night and now a
for Magnus prepares a5 to push away the
Queen is six preparing to develop the
dark square bishop and now a5 and in the
classical game 11 went for Quint a 7 but
here he goes Queen to d8 and this is the
real new move of the game so it is as of
move tendered we have a completely new
game nights the e5 Magnus centralizes
the knight and offers afraid of light
square Bishop s' here 11 trades Bishop
captures Queen captures and rook the c8
now continuous development Magnus goes
c3 the seat upon will not be a target in
the future and also you
strengthen the center Bishop to e7 and
now h4 by Magnus so first a four a five
and now h4 playing on both sides of the
board something that's always very
enjoyable and you leave the option of
maybe I'll cast on maybe I'll just go
rook h3 room g3 now you never know so
very flexible the level trades once in
the center and Knight captures on e5
Bishop characters and now Knight to d7
asking Magnus do you want to capture on
g7 now capturing an g7 is the best move
for white but it's more of a move for a
classical game it's not a move for a
rapid game and I will just show it
because it features a very interesting
trap Bishop captures rook g8 bishop
moves and now rook captures and g2 and
now the move you had to find with white
in order to go for Bishop captures and
g7 is the Bishop to g5 it looks stupid
since I mean why just give up material
here but the point is if Bishop captures
the Bishop captures Bishop then King f1
traps the rook that's that's the trap so
the the point is after Bishop g5 you
were gonna have to go Queen c7 create an
escape route for the rook Queen f3
you're attacking the rook rook h2
captures captures and now you're Castle
queenside and now white will be slightly
better I would would somewhat safer King
and the black king is still in the
center of the board but like I said it
requires a lot of calculation and Magnus
was not interested in investing time as
it is a rapid game so h5 prepared to
meet meeting castles with just h6 with
first Knight captures an e5 now Queen
captures an e5 is possible but Magnus
goes for D captures on e5 because if 11
castles King side Magnus wants to be
able to shift the rook this way to help
out with the attack against the black
king so 11 dust castle and the Magnus
immediately goes for the very nice rook
lift we have Queen to d7 attacking the
rook preparing to push f5 rope the g4
and now f5 just pushing the rook away
and Magnus decides to capture here on
poisson we have captures Bishop captures
and now Magnus castles also maybe
h6 right away or or just starting to
bring the rook into the game is also
possible but Magnus decides that castle
first you know Safety's first and
if needed he will do another nice rook
lift this way and here 11 starts pushing
in the central with E 5 he perhaps
should have played age sex prevent
Magnus for pushing age sex but he
doesn't mind he just pushes e5 with h6
and now King
8 shape and ok we have pawn captures
Bishop captures and now Magnus brings
the rook to d1 repairs rogue d3 and the
rugby g3 or h3 depending on what black
plays we have Queen to f7 11 also wants
to create a rook Queen rook battery on
the F file to put pressure on the f2
pawn now we looked at d3 by Magnus and
the now II for taking away the f3 square
from what from the white rook so rook
the h3 now rook the g3 also possible but
you can defend with rudy' g8 or just
Bishop to f6 so it's not going to be a
problem Magnus goes rook to h3 he wants
the double rooks and the H file and we
have looked the c6 now preparing rook to
f6 and the rook jito h4 now the threat
of course is rook captures on a
seven-eleven defends with h6 and now
Queen to III adding another attacker to
the h6 pawn we have looked at f6
11 adds another attacker to the f2 pawn
and now the problem well the problem for
black is that everything is nicely
positioned you know there is no way to
improve the position for black this
Bishop is pretty much stuck here
guarding the h6 pawn however Magnus has
a photo moment a useless night on unbe 3
and he has the opportunity to become a
very useful piece so he just goes
Knights to d4 and now 11 has some
problems finding an active move or or
finding him a move at all because you
can't really move any of the pawns you
can't move the bishop you don't really
have good moves with the queen or the
rook you could try some like Ruby g6 but
basically you need a waiting move so
best for Lemon is just King to g8 and
you know then he waits for Magnus to
figure out what to do if rook g3 just
count red rook g6
if phrase you can just pretty much trade
everything captures captures captures
even this this captures and now you play
this slightly worse endgame as black but
you should be okay however after Knight
to the
4:11 captured an f2 rook captures an f2
and this doesn't work this this loses
the game now but it's not at all
simple white loses the game so feel free
to pause the video and try to figure out
why this loses the game well I give you
a couple of seconds now for those of you
who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a such a
nice move as like I said it's not simple
and I'm sure you all found route capers
and h6 so congratulations on that
the problem is 11 of course will not
capture and allow this mate
with Queen 288 so of course after rook
captures on h6 11 plate came to g8 and
this is basically the position you had
to solve when you were thinking of rook
captures in h6 how do you continue the
attack and now if you if you haven't
found out now pause the video and try to
continue this attack with white so for
those of you who were able to do that
congratulations as there is pretty only
one winning way to continue this attack
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show its Queen to g3 and Queen
g3 is why rook captures on f2 losses
because now you pin the bishop and now
you have the threat of rook to h8 mate
so you have to prevent this 11 plate
rook to f1 check King to h2 and Queen to
f4 now you have to give the king and
escape routes on our roof tha it will
not be made but here Magnus just played
96 with a nice fork here but there a
rope to g6 is also sufficient for a win
it's basically the same move only via a
different move order because after this
Ruby 6 move you can trade characters
captures and how do you save the bishop
you can try the finning at once but
white gets another attack or like we
said this Knight and b3 pretty useless
but after d4 in e6 wins the game so
there's no way to add another defender
to the bishop so instead 11 try after
night Stewie 611 tried Queen captures
and g3 right away
rook captures rook rook a to f7 now
defending the bishop and now just rook H
to g6 Magnus gets another look into the
game and now III 11 gives up a piece
hoping to get e 2 and D 1 a to promote
to a queen and here the idea is that if
let's say characters characters and
captures with chair King h8 now
have some problems how do you stop the
pond here although it's it's not all
that problematic and Magnus had some 20
minutes on the clock so he had quite
quite enough time to calculate this the
point is you have to go rookie 7 just
put the room behind the past pawn and if
e 2 now you play rook check King moves
you cannot go here the night covers that
Knight g5 checking g6 and Knight f3 now
the rook and the knight control the
queening square and you're just down a
piece in a completely lost position so
here after e3 like I said rogue
characters is possible but Magnus you
know goes for the capablanca principle
the lazy the lazy maneuver and he just
captures the past pawn so now it was in
this position on move 36 that Levin
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here the white rook will
just return to g3 and again you will
lose a piece or you can try to unpin
immediately and then go into this
terrible endgame after characters
characters captures captures and the
rookie 7 check King of 6 rook captures
here you will have a row component game
where Magnus's has 4 points to 2 and
this is again a very weak points or
gonna lose more points of course xi
knows that there there's no way to play
this against Magnus
so after Luke captures an e3 he just
resigned the game like I said if if this
wasn't enough
of course Magnus would calculate rook
captures and g7 he had more than 20
minutes on the clock but there was no
need so he just captured it and that's
also fine so and before we forget we do
have a photo of all the participants of
the Grantchester finals so here it is
but I will only show you a portion of
the photo because there is a secret
question for you so here's the photo
which one of these gentlemen is 11 now
you have to guess it it's not an easy
question I know only one of them can be
11 so you know do take your time
now let's let's check it out which one
of these gentlemen is lemon now of
course for those of you who have been
following the channel for quite some
time of course you know that 11 is the
most colorful Grandmaster so there you
have it the one with the green shoes is
of course lemon and these are all of
them being winning first place you can
see his nice trophy there MVL second
Magnus third and 11 in fourth place it's
a bit odd that ding is not in the middle
of the photo but I guess they just don't
don't you know mind things like that and
also I think the its little I'd expect a
bigger trophy for the winner of the
grand chester finals you you know you
fight for an entire year to be here and
now you win it and it looks like well it
looks like a vos and I don't know I've
seen I've seen nicer trophies in in much
smaller tournaments but then again ok
you do have a 150,000 dollars a cash
prize for winning first place so I guess
it's not all about the trophy or maybe I
just have terrible taste in trophies
that's there's there's also death but
yeah yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you've enjoyed my
short coverage of the Grantchester
Magnus Indy and the rapid match was
drawn the Blitz game was also drawn one
with Magnus one win 11 and two games
were drawn
so basically Coulson's win in the
classical time section which were him
six points you know made me made his win
in the match possible robbery I would
like to think learn it pro coupe it's
Armin Fabian Donald Mathewson Jeff jolly
and Kenneth McKay of Scotland for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos Europe
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions we are soon starting also
our next big saga but the December is
really packed with a lot of chess events
you have the final leg of the
Grantchester where we have to see if mvl
will secure his spot in the candidates
tournament or not and we also have the
world rapid and blitz championship
taking place ugly from 26th to New
Year's so really December is just packed
with chess so we have our work cut out
for us so once again I do hope you
enjoyed it and have an excellent the
rest of your day and I will see you soon